today's show is sponsored by new Findus
toilet wallets we're not sure what they
are either we sell them you smell em
opening technical difficulties here huh
playing citation needed I have an almost
randomly selected article from
everybody's favorite source of knowledge
Wikipedia in front of me and these folks
cannot see it every fact they get right
is a point and a ding and there is a
prize for particular good answers which
is and your topic today is simple human
hello pass a bigger shovel we're going
to be digging deep today I use the
cardinal directions of up down left and
right I think I caught the [ __ ] is it is
it like this the whole sort of simple
English thing or something or like a
simpler version of the one yeah it sort
of an overall thing to try and achieve
that in humanity or something online is
it an album oh no it's not that's a nice
nice prog rock album time and that's a
simple hero's is pretty much granddaddy
yeah yeah it's something like I thought
it would be something like that okay
okay let's get the opposite is it an LP
is it is it is it a film or something it
media is it not media at all okay is it
some kind of like eco revolution oh not
really
I'll show like a good like a notion
about how mankind used to exist pre
belushin Airy or something like that all
thinking really quite quite big picture
here and not at all commercial
commercial commercial outta damnit bog
roll oh you know what you get the point
ah they make rubbish bins but that's
quality I'm gonna that's like standing
in a pool with a dart in your hand
spinning around three times with your
eyes dollars doing that Gator balls are
that's how I played us and that's why
you're banned actually I've seen it
played out flailing like actually to the
other side agility or I'm sated to be
fair each each more like standing in a
pub with you dart dart in your hand a
point in the other hand throwing at the
dartboard and knocking everything down
in the skit line so simple human mate
business they do um they they are
considered I quote here amongst the most
high-end trash cans on the market today
can you tell me why why are they some of
the best they were Acrobat are they
antibacterial of my micro viable my
write down the answer no hi are they
made of gold or diamonds or something
otherwise desirable I'll give you a
point for the diamonds it's carbon it's
durability durability they last a long
time one of the reasons oh I don't know
well now the number of times I've broken
my bins no yeah I can't because it's
zero yeah it's yeah I yes
all right I've never brought in a
wheelie bin or anything in my life I
mean I've ridden in wood and I've never
broken it are we talking dumpster stylee
thing yeah I'm serious industrial know
we're talking um sort of mature yeah
kitchen bins I don't breakable - John do
they do this solar compacting thing are
they older proof older they provide a
nice tune when you put something in them
good loser in the do they make SOT oh I
give away like I feel or some soft drink
or other that gave you a little thing
that you attached your bin that made a
noise every time you open what was the
noise it's noise alright you've come on
lent from the pub or night you in my
situation that you're married man you've
snuck back in not wanting to wear the
wife ought you taking your shoes off
you've done the lot you've sneakily
eaten the kebab that you said you were
gonna have you tiptoe over Lynn but
butter
you know at this point is good you've
taken your shoes off because you're
sleeping on the couch yeah wherever you
be that kind of thing
great thanks making a noisy bin thing
you're right about
technologically-advanced bins here but
it's one thing in particular check no
bins no that's just bins that damage to
repetitive music this is not a product
placement just what random are pulled up
for me does it shift and sort and do you
recycling for you no it's much less
advanced than that does it play Freebird
does it let you put rubbish in eat no
yes yes what what would make that front
flap Oh more easy than an open mouth
it's not open mouth he's got an
automatic lid bingo oh you it has an
automatic sensor activated lid I think
I've seen adverts for that now yep what
what you movie night on a silly channel
but no one ever watches anyway so you'll
wave it it play a trumpet call it
there is just no hope left for Humanity
is there really this is basically wave
your hand towards the bin if you cancel
it and it opens for you until of course
it breaks down at which point does but
they don't break it says what I was in
the bin turns against you starts
throwing banana peels in your face which
will happen when the monkeys take over
the world anyway what else have they
added sensors to cuz there's all the
kitchen and bathroom stuff they've added
sensors to Oh
knives I've seen sensors in 900 what Fox
sorry No
Oh God - curry tonight it's gonna be
entertaining what would you do to a for
what possible when you're cooking a
steak you put it's got a temperature
probe on it and it tells you raining but
Roger probe so surely you just need a
knife and a temperature probe why when
you can have it in a fork that you can
they use to eat it or something I don't
know but it was a thing you stuck in a
steak there was another bad pan they've
put a 10th century in a pan as well what
for steak again mark I've seen it on a
shopping channel of a pan that will tell
you of what manner your steak will be
done at the current temperature I per
issue this is that brown washes shopping
channels course I was shopping
a married man balls occasionally we go
down the chapel Johnson go nah nah brah
sorry love no brah trousers that make
your ass look better black one
soulful posture as well we're actually
looking in the bathroom for this scales
toilet I like the idea that they put an
insensitive in the scale yeah step off
lardo I can't take this anymore
that's the old gag there isn't it you
step on the step on the scales there's
one at a time please
no coach partners bog roll that's a good
place no it's not actually it's very
obvious univer not a bog roll but that
answers already got me point taunts
before so I thought I'd try yeah it's
not absurd though I mean not in a
private bathroom but in like works ones
because you've got the automatic tap
senses yeah I've seen ones for room you
enclose an automatic tap sense as well
yeah and there's there's the things
where you give it that number and it
gives you a couple of sheets to dry your
hands on so bug rolls just the next one
on that see what different amount still
there yeah but you just go you've based
toilets everything in the bathroom apart
from the one you've got the wrong toilet
clothes hang go point oh yeah just go
back to your girl thing do you want to
be stuck in a work in setting in a
cubicle try it if it you go out you have
to do this or something to get the
toilet it would be right for the Queen
yeah do you never stop [ __ ] she just be
surrounded she like slowly just this
time it's the paper wiring on her
wedding dress he's winding around
she looks like an ollie and Rex puppy
when they're fine but the other thing
thing on a toilet roll dispenser taenia
it like like you say at a public water
there's not much left
go careful now yeah if it was a curry
choose another stall is that what toilet
tenders used to probably do you imagine
not that one she's out he was no more
one um can you tell me anywhere they
might be sold looking for American
retail stores Walmart well possibly the
willing for some more Bed Bath and
Beyond at point-o dance Mart on I always
did wonder what beyond words
electric bends electric speak is basic
speaky clever bins and toilet roll
warning devices danger bog roll
I won't danger Bob haha each sheet a new
danger this one is how many crocodiles
there doesn't seem to be anything wrong
with this one
poison ivy ha ha ha why would I she's
lovely
ah no just just you've got Russian
Roulette toilet paper ones chilly one
chic as icing yeah one cheat out of
every six house boys now have your
capsule I sneeze ah yes one out of six
spearmint a little tingly but not
necessarily wrong sorts can it ah TCP
whoa t3 that would spice up toilet race
would rather than toilet ah whoa we
laugh at you oh yes I've got in my head
Oh Pat Sajak you Americans out there
spinning the wheel we wonder what it'll
and them I'm sorry that's porcupine
you've got hello Barry oh here
hey does that want to tell me what Bed
Bath & Beyond used to be quarks the
first one opened in 1971 it had a
different name and something really
prosaic like Harrison's home society
privy in whatever I'd say it's about
one-third more prosaic bed and bath oh
wait we're selling more than just beds
and baths what do we call it bad bath
beyond only do everybody's we knock off
early their bath and a third item come
in to see what it is yeah I need some
pillows a new plug for the bath and some
tarot cards that was a second version
we're just hanging off the edge a bath
and tear oh god this bed bath pillows
some other things and look at while
we're on Bed Bath & Beyond bar since we
seem to be going down this wiki hole um
they've bought a lot of companies can
you tell me what the name of the company
that sold Christmas trees was that they
bought about 2003 Green Prix what Chris
Masterson's Christmas trees through all
the offering far too seriously the
Christmas tree shop point god I was so
close
what do you sell cars alright there is
one last thing that simple human cell
are which is a sensor mirror can you
tell me what it does tells you you're
ugly as I said very floral what what how
do I look today
you know northern my friend in dreadful
is it is it a senseless mirror oh dude
senseless idiot
really insane why is if you leave the
house a sense of air having what does it
tire you've brush etz us all the senses
so far are just if something is close to
it like it's not much of a sense it turn
the lights on point it is alike so if
you're close to the mirror yes sir oh
you know you're close to the mirror if
the lights aren't on sir your series M
Sameera porn boy camera light switch
which is to settle the other yeah I I've
sensed the mirror why did I in Starling
be there right I gotta tell the lights
up again now mera mera on the poor are
you all right at the end of the other
it's dangerous I was going the whole
time
honey will you switch on the light in
the living room
I don't want to use the wish this puzzle
I need to fry some bacon can eat upon
the gas I'll be end of that
congratulations Matt you did score all
the Jenny money to get the acid2 variety
very win a gift voucher to everyone's
favorite communist High Street shop
which is Marks and Spencer so until then
that's been Matt gray that's been Gary
Brannan that's been Chris Joel how big
Tom Scott we'll see you next time
hey thanks for watching if you liked the
show then tell someone tell us or send
us a telegram and there are all new
episodes of our reverse trivia podcast
over at Tech disco UK